We're going to have a completely absurd summer, it
was somehow like 6 number 1 singles with
capital in a row at the same time,
and we had exactly 2 plastic palms with 500
HP, so that was that one magical
year where the knot
was completely broken.
Welcome to the OMR  Today's podcast as you
know it from us is once again a
detour into a well digital business
corner that is actually music
business but is just business and that's
why it suits us well and I'm happy
about two guests who you don't really
know as much as you actually do
everyone here tells me they are
really
tough players in the German-speaking music
business, their names are Tim Wilke and David
Kraft and they call themselves the grace hi hi
thank you for allowing us to be here hello thank you
very much so um I'm really
scared or that's exactly how I
came from  We're from
the sample beat-building so where you
somehow take old pieces,
especially from the 70s and 80s,
flip the new ones as we say and
put down the drums and the crails are the
record boxes and that's actually where
the name comes from, so it was the 90s  Yes, it was so
common that every producer
somehow had a drum machine with,
I don't know if you're
probably familiar with that, with like 16
pets that you hit on it and they were
samplers, so um in machines
with an audio input where you can then use one  For
example, you could connect a record player to it and feed in the audio material via the
record player and
then cut it up and that's how
this sampling process
came about, where you basically
cut pieces and reassembled them,
which is still
done a lot in techno or just in  Hip
hop
and the term for this sample
look for samples so really
look for samples in record crates, for
example in the soul or catch area, that's what
they called things in the crates
back then and exactly
how do two guys come
from childhood days, not
directly but very much  Since my youth
in Göttingen,
how do you get into the music business
with particularly good music lessons
or how do you get started So
actually it was all, um,
self-taught, so Dave also
had piano lessons and I also had
drum lessons, which actually has a
relatively small amount of
music  Theoretical basics have relatively little
to do with what we
did in the Essence, which was
actually more of a
fan perspective of being a hip hop fan in some way,
I would say, and
then
dealing with how the beats are built
and here we come  Yes, from the time
when you had access to YouTube and stuff like that to
kind of see how it was done, especially
in promotional phases, I would say
from American producers
who have now also stamped things or something like that
you could see a little bit about what kind of
programs they use
or what kind of
hardware they use
and then you just
dealt with it and exchanged
the upper level or or
so I think I really started with it so
what does it really mean
because  Doing it as a hobby maybe
filled with 13 so now 20
years ago 20 hours
met or
the hip hopsine quotes if
you can call it that in Götting it's
just not that big and then
you just stumble over each other then
you say hey you always know him  but also
beats like that nonsense with each other
and then we just talked about it
like we met through mutual
friends that was me I was also
when we both actually have
today we're also a
bit ashamed of both of them I
also rapped  There was even a band with
another rapper, there were
four
instrument people there, from
drums to even oboe and everything like
that, it was a bit of a mixture
between hip hop rock scar type music,
I'll say, and also
on the side  The beats were also
produced digitally for the projects because
we did them live with a band and
the music itself was produced digitally on
the computer at home
and I had already
made the beats for it and Dave's brother
also rapped and then we knew
a little bit about each other who
was who and
Göttingen isn't a huge city
if you
're out and about, drinking here and there in
the clubs and so of course you get
into conversation and we do
They had a bit of the same
area anyway, the same quarter over two three
corners, you always know it
somehow and then you did ball after you graduated from
high school, yes, and then
somehow the decision was made afterwards. It didn't happen that quickly,
so it was already
during your school days or something like that  We
really earned money
during our studies,
I would say, during
my school days, I don't
really think a little bit yet, but I mean, look if you
think about it, I'd say that's the time when
you learn the basics  of marketing
and networking I
mean that was already like that, you remember
rock so there was
a platform back then that was in 2006 um also
by an American
producer called rockwilder who has something like that
for Redman and Method Man and  To
produce things like that, he had a
platform where you could
beg beats against each other and people
could vote on which beat was
better, but you could also
sell them via Paypal and it was
just a bit of a system
who wins a lot of battles  It
also comes up in the rankings and can
sell beats and we were relatively
far along so that you could get it
visible on the platform,
it wasn't exclusive, it was
just
tried for $5 to $10 but you could
Sell ​​it several times and, um,
a few hundred euros of income
or something like that, definitely and
then it really started, you can
really say that we were
able to live on that, that was
actually the case during our studies, so
we could definitely do anything  In this case, both of them
had to study in a relaxed way,
somehow not during that time, but
somehow bypassing it, exactly so
I only
studied yoga for a semester and then I went
back to Göttingen and did
an industrial engineering degree
then it wasn't done anymore because at
some point the beat was sold, well that was
even at the time when we
were in Berlin, we moved to Berlin after that,
then this started with all the
connections and then I
really just didn't have the time anymore,
so I  I still had
to do an internship for half a year
unpaid and did my bachelor's theses.
Then I sort of weighed up whether
I wanted to do that or whether I would rather
concentrate on music.
Yes, I
actually finished my studies, but that was just because of that
the practitioners
who were linked to it for me because
I had finished studying noise, i.e. sports
and English at the Gymnasialand and the
school practitioners that you
do there while you're studying,
all of that was still possible at the time because the
Berlin contact wasn't yet so hugely
developed that that  was still possible because
we weren't yet
session producers in the sense that we worked in the studio
but were really
focused on this online beat sale
and then I went to hand in my
master's thesis and for my
birthday, I don't even know
anymore in
2016  Yes, 16 or 17, I think 17 or
that doesn't matter either way, in any case,
we both moved to Berlin
and by then I had
already finished my master's degree, but I
didn't do the law anymore, so
that was exactly it  Then there was
a balancing act that we knew
okay, online
beat sales are going on and that
somehow covers what you need to live
and now you have to take this shot
and transform it somehow
because we knew that
beat sales are going on, I'll put it that way  We've been
selling beats online since our infancy, so it
basically changed at the turn of the year,
how the beats were sold,
the market became so inflationary, then
at some point thousands of people joined in today,
that's how we've been
out of it for a few years now  to say
maybe even then really via
tiktok and so on, to be honest,
this whole thing as we still knew it
with us, just YouTube, or that you
somehow uploaded the beats to the
animated video on YouTube
and then somehow
bought ADS on it  and so on and
somehow it was pretty good,
um, and then if you were lucky
you somehow got into the YouTube trends
and so on with the beats,
but that was a
struggle, you have to say, because brands
were bought or other artists
more other artists or independent
artists, mostly somehow from the USA
or from many different
countries,
but that's cool. I would now imagine that
's not 50 dollars or 100 dollars
or something like that
if you're a rapper now and
you're now on the  Looking for the
beat that sounds like a Kanye
West or Travis Scott beat then of
course people enter it on YouTube so
there really was this Travis Scott
type beat or something like that and then
you just have beats where you
yourself  said okay, that could
be a Travis Scott tape beat where Travis
Scott could rap on it, whether you
uploaded it and that just linked it to
his Beats Dorfer, so
the most common beatstore platform
these days, we also had
shares in it that are still Beats
stars  .com
you can still sell your beats
and then get the money
via Paypal or whatever and they
then automatically send the
license agreements and so on.
Nowadays everything is done with AI and so you read
a lot of things that
could change everything  What's
really big for you now is a role,
I find it a bit difficult to
say, so you can kind of
say what you think, I think from that
perspective,
which is of course super interesting,
you can now recreate voices
People can somehow
have music artificially generated and and and
but I just don't know whether that's the case, so
many
people are still thinking that AI does
n't really have that sense of
aesthetics that humans finally have
and I think I just have this
nose for what the next thing
is or how music can develop.
I don't know whether AI has become
independent enough to be
able to implement it somehow, so it's kind of
hard for me to
assess that because I think these are trends
Recognizing and anticipating in advance,
I dare to doubt that I
rather believe that AI
can reproduce like this anymore,
so I think it depends. I
can imagine that there are
already a lot of
websites and stuff like that where you can
somehow get a piece of guitar, for example  feeds it in
and the AI ​​makes it longer and gets
something different out of it but I do
n't think so personally now I do
n't really feel threatened by it I have to
say my music is also just really
a lot of this personal in the studio
and um also interact with the artist
Rappers in our case and
somehow build a personal relationship
and somehow give advice and so
on, it's actually
not just about making music
according to the motto of what you've uploaded there, they
may not be able to
produce videos very independently, somehow produce texts
Logically and of course I think
it's so different so you ca
n't do that somehow now, it's still
a lot of clickbait to
be honest what if you somehow
get something welded into the algorithm of
Tiktok and somehow
generated Drake  Song or something like that, I
once did it for fun, so you
still have to write a text yourself,
you have to rap it yourself
and then you can have the audio
file reversed to Drake by the AI ​​so
that I sound like that, but you can do
it  But don't press the button and say
hey, do Dragon, it
definitely doesn't work that way yet, yes, it probably works too, so
this AI topic, I've also
listened to quite a lot of what
the different opinions are
and I also believe that
Maybe we are, I don't want
to say, too old and can really
be judged, but it's just exactly the same thing.
If I
think about it, I think what we did when we were
15 or 16 on Fruity Loops or
Logic or something like that with beats
build and then somehow start
selling beats online. I think that
's
suspicious now, so previous generations who
made 90s hip hop did
n't understand it at all and that's
maybe one of the reasons why
we've been very successful now because
we're so into it  We built up the catalog and
then prepared it when we
came to Berlin, we had 1000
beats and somehow we had this
second mainstay that made us independent
and so we did
n't have to bend too much
and I think that's
just the next step  The thing is that
the next generation of kids who
maybe have full master brains will
connect with AI and produce and upload the
commands and automatically generate content.
New people will come along and then
sort of take everything apart in that way
that the
producer can do the job or at
some point you are from your, so to speak, from
your work and from your rights and
then or so I think if you feel
like it you can
do it, so
I wouldn't see any reason for you to
somehow be in  In five years or
in 10 or 20,
the younger people will no longer be able to do that, they will have descendants who
have a more modern musical feel or something like that.
I mean, with us there is a
bit of a difference. Again, we
are not only active as producers,
but also as publishers and we
Newer producers are also signing a
contract, some of whom
are now 10 years younger than us or
so exactly yes exactly
Search from from BMG oh, okay, so
you probably know him, yes, so
yes, you've already prepared for two
events  let's see that now not so
that you have
alreadybought
together with the BMG so we have
suitcases, Antra music was together with the BMG
and the works that are generated by the
publishing house, we ourselves are
also under contract with our own publishing house,
that means the works that  are
generated end up in there too and
yes okay that's so that's it, so
to speak,
yes you just have to imagine
that it is active if you
want to see it like that now, business technical
assets are also created then they
somehow work for us
But we also offer
resources for our authors in return,
so the thing is, our publisher
hasn't been around that
long, I would say for two
years or so, so it
actually has to be some kind of track,
I would  already estimate with Bones or
something, maybe blue light if
it could be there,
listen to the rights privately, so to speak,
directly with the BMG in the publisher, which means
the rights are then there so what is it
then you don't have anything from
them in the long term  Well,
intellectual property can't be
taken away in Germany, so
it doesn't always come down to that, so you just
have to imagine it that way,
so you have to go a little further into
the branches, so to speak, through which
you now earn money as a music producer
For us,
the publisher that we now have also added
extra shows, but
as a rule I would say that you
always have the production costs,
someone pays you to
produce them in the first place, then you have
the licenses again  That's exactly what you
mean, like streaming, a name,
album sales, all the money that comes through,
I'll say label or
sales things and then there's
the publishing right, which is
the biggest thing for producers anyway in that sense  That's what it means when
your music is played on the radio,
blah blah, you get your tanteam. That's exactly what
the three sources of income are, that
is, when there's blue light through a
team, they're running now, maybe for a
lifetime, the thing will probably
always be heard for a few years and  Of
course you can make a good living from it or
yes, as I said, you
just get it from a publisher if you
sign it somewhere. You can
either say I'm not published, I'll look
into it myself at GEMA and then
the money comes directly to you or  You
go to a publisher and give a little
advance so that you
can basically live on it and you have to
play again with your
aunts, just like stupidly said, like when
the
publisher gives them as a bank loan and you
play it back into one
So they grab a certain split, so
to speak, from the game distributions,
and then they take their percentage, so to speak, and depending on how successful you
are in the publishing industry, the better
the conditions are. It's actually like the
real estate game, if you will, the more
real estate you have, the better
the conditions  you get it from the bank and
at some point you'll get to the point
where you might have your own
real estate group or a
publishing house yourself and that's actually something
like what kind of
sales your company makes,
what's the current situation where we are so
it is  It's a bit difficult
to estimate because the publishing house
is still relatively new, but
I would say that we now have
between 20 and 30
producers and songwriters with us and
are also part of the publishing house ourselves
and so we as a producer team are
already counting  to the
more successful producers in
Germany, that means
that the sales that
go through there every year are already
millions, which then
go through a cash flow, so not 10 20
million, so out of five six seven
or so,
I would now have to look at the numbers,
so now that's it  It's a bit
difficult to unravel because
our structure consists of so many different
partnerships, so we have
the co-publishing house with BMG
and it's also an
independent GmbH, so to speak, where the
studio manager, for example,
is also an employee of us
The songwriters and producers are still designing in the publishing house itself,
but we ourselves
now also have a management deal
with an agency where there
are artists under contract again with whom we
work together again and make albums and
then just get paid for production,
so that's it  It's just a
bit so divided across all these
income streams that you ca
n't really say exactly,
so the publisher itself doesn't have
many employees, so we have
Theo as a product manager and we have
a lawyer, but I think also through the
management company  The employee is also divided in
exactly the same way, so the thing is,
you just have to look at it a little bit like that, the
management agency that manages us,
so
RBK is also
our partnership in the publishing house and the
resources are now a
bit limited, so it is  Well, the
people who
do the accounting in our management
also work for the publishing house in a figurative sense,
so it's all
a bit overarching if you
really
add up all the resources and how many people are
somehow involved  There are
probably actually 40 50
people who have something to do with it.
Discuss your career to the end, so to speak,
broken off
to some extent and pay the rent
and then I saw in the research that there was
somehow a
breakthrough that got a bigger rapper to
you  or wanted to work with you
then it was different, it wasn't that
direct, it wasn't like that at all, so
through our online beat sales
an artist from
Berlin simply wrote to us and said that my
name was me and
why tell the whole story,
well actually  He even wanted to, as
he recognized, a colleague who also
makes beats himself
and asked the question: can you imitate the beat
because he assumed
that we were somehow based in the USA
but that the entire website was in English
and so on,
his colleague, no, they are  Germans, they
've already worked with a few people in
Germany and then
we just called and talked to each other
somehow and then
Joschi said he's coming
to Berlin again, I also have a studio
that I can access and then
we're there
I don't know, three, four, five times,
maybe even more often, first we
went to Berlin, always on
weekends, and working with him there
alongside our studies, exactly next to our
studies, always on the weekends when we
somehow had nothing to do and, um,
the studio was  Just from Raf Camora,
our current partner's studies are basically,
um, exactly
jumping around, no, so those were
at the time then really,
so Raffa at the time, for example,
Raf Camora did a
bit of executive production at kontra K at the time
and then he did  We also
noticed relatively quickly that we were
working quite successfully with Yoshi and
then he gave us two
tracks from kontra K, for
example, which we produced from
them. A
gold single was created from them, for example Soldiers from
kontra K, which laid the foundation  laid down
for work with kontra K then
Bausa was suddenly between the tour stop
at Palmen aus Plastik on the Palmen
aus plastic tour by Raf and Bauens there
at RAF in the studio or did we
suddenly work with Bowser on the weekend
and and we worked relatively
quickly  I noticed that there were a lot of
people jumping around, it was kind of like a
hotspot, there were a lot of newcomers,
the studio
was exactly and it was just
a totally messed up
basement studio where Rafa stopped before
he and Bones went through the roof too  He
had his own little studio and
basically just did his own stuff
and because Joschi and Rafael had been
friends for a long
time and Raff was already doing a
bit of
artist and
producer management at the time,
he told us that  Foresight
also made a little bit available
to work there because he
knew, okay, um, I would
n't even assume that it was
somehow a calculation on Rafa's part or something like that,
but of course he knew if the
guys there were going
to build something successful and  the studio or now um
is used while I
'm on the road by people who also
produce me and my boys
and can grab my arms underneath it,
it's kind of a win-win
situation and that's how it
all came about that we then  Well,
contrary to K, we produced with Kapital
then capital bra, which Yoshi
also recorded with them at the time. We
somehow had 6 number 1 singles
in a row and and and and and his
most successful song that you have ever
recorded,
it depends, I think  now
in general probably what you
call love already from browser or 500
or 500 hp from raffen Bauens
really crazy statistics after you have
already said that yourself not
only been successful but incredibly
successful so really or the
colleague
showed me preparation there is like that  from the
Federal Association of the Music Industry so
charts where you somehow,
wait a minute, the page number 5 of the
records sold in Germany has 15.8
million
fingers in it obviously and that
's just somehow right after
Herbert Grönemeyer and Ed Sheeran so yes yes
that's also the case now if you  now after
number 1 singles in Germany, for example,
I think we are also at number 3 in
German music history,
so Dieter Bohlen has 23 and I
think that's John Lennon or something or
another 22 and we have 19 18 or 19 okay
1 number 1 in  Germany, yes, yes,
dude, but
that's
probably because rap has
somehow become huge in
the last few years. Of course,
we were also really lucky,
so we were also just
lucky who we met again in the
studio and it was also in that
For example,
we were simply introduced to Kappi by
Yoshi. He said, hey, he's a
street rapper or something like that. He wanted to
do a little something for him and
we never thought
that we would end up with him at some point
I don't know exactly seven number ones, that's why
we had four with him, I think, or where we had six in
a row with him, that's how we had
a completely absurd summer, that was
somehow like 6 number 1 singles with
capital in a row at the same time, and
then
and  Exactly and palm trees made of plastic 2 where
500 HP so that was that one
magical year where the knot just
completely burst somehow
blocked no I mean exactly but also
consciously so that's
a bit of a decision
that we already live our lives more like that  We
want
to stay in the studio and continue
working on music and we also work as act
the crates, we have also
released albums, producer albums, but
now we want to push ourselves so blatantly into the foreground
and somehow
find ourselves as a city  Relatively
consciously not because we also
have a family life and
they are both parents and
we don't want to
be recognized too much everywhere or so
recognize the song
that doesn't matter so that was a
side that was somehow conscious but we
also have it
I just missed the point a bit, I have to
say to be honest, because we
already had ten number ones, so
now we want to somehow start
making another product to go with it, so it would be
a bit silly
to do that now, so we thought no
Just let it stay in the song like that, so
to speak.
I think at the time
when everything exploded so much for us, there were
artists who would have
gone along with it with the tag and some who
wouldn't have gone along with it because that
's the thing  Even if you're
producing a record for someone and you're
forcing your producer day on
his entire record, on every track
there's something about it that's a
bit invasive and
sometimes perhaps not
timeless, so I'll say it's a
track like that  like what you call love would
perhaps be strange if
the createst came at the beginning because
that's already the first modern
hit rap song, it even
played somehow at the
Oktoberfest and so up and down that
was  Also the first time when you
noticed, okay, that now really
big ladies and somehow people from the
university called us at the time and
said hey, at every house party
this song is playing for you in the end,
so the text belongs entirely to
Bowser  The difference is a bit
that Bausa is also involved in the production,
so
he is one of the few who actually
adds the chords or something to the production process himself, so it is
always included in the music and we
have  We also produced the song
together with another producer team,
so we ourselves now have
significantly less share in what you call dear
than with 500 hp exactly
or the whole thing
exactly normally it is a text 50%
music gamers but the music always has
us  just divided by more people
so it's just somehow otherwise the
case is
Spotify worldies when we go here
no so the thing is just um this
whole royalty game that's just
licensing business I say now there's
the difference again that's just it
yes, always linked to album or single deals
that the artist or the ACT
has with the label, so if we
now as the crails
release an album as producers, then
of course we have to somehow convince the artist to
get on our album and
that he also something  of course he has more of it because he can
drop albums himself when he
grows up, so now a Bones
actually has more of it if he
releases an album himself because then
more of his album deal stays with
him but if we as producers
say okay, we'll share  that
somehow and we find that we cover
the video costs or something like that then no, we
somehow agree that we should
share it somehow but as a rule
it is more common practice if you now
produce as a contract producer for others that you actually
would from so that  Sometimes in the music industry
you are entitled to have 100% licenses on
the mountain, which is called points in this
case license points that you as a
producer usually
in rap have something between three and
five points percent on the blame of
the licenses  and of course that is
again a
separate branch of income from
publishing rights, so
you always have publishing rights, so to speak, in a
split depending on how many people are involved in
producing or writing on the
number
exactly yes
exactly or just so there are
also producers or  We also do that
sometimes with
writing on the tracks then you can
also get some of the lyrics that always have them,
for example like with Dieter Bohlen, I
heard the episode with you and he
now has Yamaha Soul, for example
he wrote it and then it will
be the case that I think he probably
gave the music and text Gamer full value completely 100% so there is
also the fact that you as a producer say
I will write and produce the
song for you, I have the full GEMA but
you keep it  Licenses for your album
deal or I only take five
percent of it or
what then so you don't have to name your own song
but what then Johanna do
you ever have soul what is the thing that
the song would probably be a royalties over
that is already several so I  I would
estimate several
million dollars over time, which is
definitely a song, no,
definitely because the thing is, so
Dieter Bohlen also says
that I also get cover requests on a
weekly or monthly basis
You have to
imagine that
with what you call love, for example,
we also received a cover request from Russia from the relatively
big artist
Sayonara Boy. There is also a
Russian artist,
I think Erias Trefi or something like that
somehow also has a cover version  Done
and if you release it
then you also have the GEMA to
a certain split and if Dieter
Bohlen releases hard soul a thousand times
then the song floats around
everywhere in all variations and
the collected for it  GEMA and so of
course it's the same for us in
some way, but I think
that's the moment when we'll
be in Classic for certain people in 20 or 30 years and they'll want to
shut us down again, who knows,
maybe too  It still happens one or
two times, no, I've
decided that you'll do it together, so I
mean it's a little more
common, like 100 teams, female
founders, teams as guests, but that's
somehow so dangerous for you now,
so you're yes or no from, um,
just  At
some point we decided with other products that we ca
n't really pin it down anymore
because at some point we just
decided that somehow it makes more sense
if you combine your strengths like that
because, as
I said, we were more or less
the only ones in Göttingen at the time  Somehow
really on our level I say that I
made beats and of course I know
a little bit about that.
I also say that this move
to Berlin is really
easier when you
do it all on your own. I have to say that you somehow
move to a foreign city on your own and you  If I did
n't know anyone then we said
yes, we'll just do it together, we'll
go 50/50
and yes,
the synergies were also at that
time, I think, in terms of
relevance, they could be shifted in a different way
because now that's just the way it is, we just have
management and  We have relatively fixed
artists with whom we go into sessions
and we produce them and then
we both do roughly the same thing and one
can do better with one artist and
the other can do better with the other or
or but back then it was just a
bit like that  I would say that Dave brought so much more
music theory with him
and also a bit of
production know-how in the sense of
melodic aspects.
Yes, that's true back then,
and it was more like that for me
that I
was a bit of a marketing vulture in the sense of
hey, how do we get the
network that is now being pushed forward in a
way that the leasing sellers also
do well with the instruments and
that's what we have there where we put it in  When we
built this session
game in Berlin, we just consistently dismantled the online bay
game more and more, so
we freed up resources to make music where we
needed it again in the
sessions and that's a
bit like that  such a smooth transition that
was finally completely organic,
apart from the fact that we were close friends anyway,
so we are and were just good friends
and our tastes
were always very similar, so we
never actually argue about it in any way
that we have to say it has to  in the anger
no, we have to be so
relatively relaxed, you can actually only do so,
Blade is evil or are you
committed to rap or or hip hop
or something like that so not Ballermann at all
or you could also do some kind of classical
or so of course there are things  So
if you've been
doing hip-hop for ten years or even longer,
you're of course already specialized in it,
I would say, but now
the boundaries are so blurred that
I can't even
tell the difference in terms of production, okay  Is the setting
a hip hop song or is it a
house song or is it a schlager son
so the boundaries are
definitely becoming more and more blurred so
now I couldn't do classical, for example but
you can also set it in a session with the pop artist
and there  will also get something so
I'll say so now, for example, we were
just yesterday in the studio with Domiziana, for example,
who has, I know, yes, yes,
and with her now, for example,
her music can
actually be found somewhere in
German rap  But Bubble City is
also perceived there, but if you
break it down to the production, it's
finally more
Trans House Techno influence on all
levels, even in quotation marks, almost
like Soundcloud music, if you
take an artist like
Skiago, it's this one
I also think that Friesenjung's number is a really
great artist, for example, so
exactly, exactly, and um,
for example, he's also a rapper in the
remotest sense, so
the way he technically
raps the lines and uses comparisons,
he uses raps  Deal means but
he raps on GABA Popp so
that's why it's
German rap or the Kosmos German rap
as he says, you ca
n't actually
see it as German rap anymore, so it
's different again in the area where I
now say okay, you take yourself  a
real band on the side and records it
or an orchestra or something like that.
Maybe you could even manage something like that in such a
way that you can
explain to people how you imagine it without having to write the notes,
but of
course not that  our hobby horse so
we are now actually more of a
digital producer
where does your impulse come from so it's
just something like that you hear on the internet
somehow on YouTube or Spotify
I had everything on or so the one
inspired by I don't know Rubin or who is
your hot one
So it was easier for me back then
to say that
you were
inspired by so and so that somehow you are so I
did a lot back then and no, a
producer back then like so much so boomberg
stuff he somehow did
partly also for Jason and so
produces 90s soul beats
exactly but unfortunately I have to be
honest and say that this
Spotify-ization of music means that
this
targeted listening to music is a bit lost so
you
come across new music much more easily but
you are  quickly back to the
next one so of course it's often like that
I always listen to the
plays of some kind of
brand new German rap or
some kind of
rap cavier and so on and you just come across
stuff on tiktok or YouTube but it's  Now it's
no longer as
targeted as it was back then.
There's a
bit of a curse to the whole
story, so I think it's just like
when you're a painter, you look
at pictures and see what technology was used to do
it now  painted what kind of colors were
used and so on,
I always catch myself doing it, I can
hardly hear you music anymore without
somehow analyzing it at the same time
and it's just kind of
a bit like, I know, for example, I'm
on holiday in Rhodes and then you listen
Suddenly there's something that catches you
and you just hear the chords
and it's so cool that you could actually
implement it as a beat for Raff
because
he could like the chords if you somehow
change the rhythm on them or something like that  I ca
n't
really say that now, so you're scanning
something specifically or something like that. I think
it's a little more about that
and I think that's the same thing
again when it comes to this point of AI and
this human judgment. I
think it's a lot going on these days  more about
taste so that you
somehow develop this social skill as a
producer during your studies to have a nose
for what the artist
actually likes and also wants from you,
so you do
n't necessarily see yourself as an artist as a
service provider, yes,
it's difficult  to say because we
are already relatively
narrow-minded in our opinion of what we
celebrate and now we don't say yes, so
every artist we work with attaches
a lot of importance to
what we say about the music
or what we do
Give suggestions for improvement or whether what
we're doing is cool or not,
um yes, but it's
always a balance between do you want to
force something on someone and
somehow force your sound on them
or do you just want to just
try to do something together that's so
good  It's just how easy it is and to
look at the content that
leaves the studio, the music that
comes out at the end, that's just what it's all about,
so you actually notice
more that the artists are more
interested in it together with us  to
somehow create something together that
will be as good as possible and to leave the ego
aside as much as possible.
I'll say take a look
internationally, so I mean there are
also one and two well-known German
producers who even
used to do it somehow  American stars do things, let's
just say quickly,
you could also sample
a little bit about Travis Scott and so
of course
imagine it.
We once had a phase
where we also worked a lot in that direction, so just
basically
stretched out our hand over the ocean  and we
also had a few placements
in the USA with an artist like Journal
Lucaster
for the song, but to be
honest we lost sight of it a bit
when you went to Berlin afterwards
and just put 100% of our energy into it  have
somehow concentrated on gaining a foothold here
and I don't think it's that
easy to say hey we're
successful in Germany so we're going
to the USA now and everyone will
want to work with us so
I don't think it's that easy either so we could have
Of course, somehow the
possibility of getting through connections and
any sessions definitely determines it, but we
can't just
call a bijanji and say that my session
with Drake is still not that easy,
so yes, I always think that there is
a bit of a balance out of whatever
scene  respects you particularly and where do
you have the best relationships,
for example with us before we
came to Berlin and then we
finally decided to
say we are now going this
way in Berlin and more on the
German scene  I used to
know that we were already aware that
we
couldn't really serve America anymore
because it was very time-consuming
to maintain the connections somehow,
so you could now
write down a bit like this: you are with them
most successful music makers of the last few
years from Germany so
we've just learned about everything so somehow
in the category really nice and Herbert
Grönemeyer American music also
entrepreneurs who also want to somehow
see how do I get the next song big
how do I get even hotter how can I
stabilize my career and  If
you then write a management
and say somehow hey we are here, this is what we are
doing, this is a bit,
by the way, our playlist, our song,
look, they are the streams and so on,
then there would probably be a
team because not Team Drake or  Team
Travis you can say okay,
the guys fly over and then
in the studio and all of a sudden in there, so that
's my amateur fantasy, it's wrong,
yes, the problem is that
in the music industry there's a lot of
thinking about exclusivity and camp
So the fact that you're
somehow
on the move in a crew like that that's a bit so
tight-knit, that's just as stupid
to say as if we're now the
in-house producers of Raf
Camora with us MC
capital versus, well, that's
all  So at that time there was a circle that
somehow acted together, who
also supported each other very strongly
and also featured each other,
then it's always been a
scene event and for us it's just so
multifactorial, so momentum
came together that it would just be a  We
were extremely lucky
that all of a sudden some of the
knots fell through and perhaps
a success arose that
cannot be replicated so quickly and of
course that has now
clearly received a huge amount of attention in Germany and has
also attracted German artists to us and so on
But I think the big
difference is now when you
have someone like Drake who
also has his three or four in-house producers and
has been friends with the media for over 10 20 years,
of course they also see that they don't have
anyone else
Somehow let producers in there for the collaboration
because,
I would say, making music together is
such an intimate process that you
have to estimate relatively precisely and know what the artist wants from you
and once you start
making music together, stop with someone  I do
n't know at all then it can also
be unpleasant if I had a wish
it would be who would I like to
do something with on the US or
right so nowadays I find it
really difficult so I think I'll
still say the principle break
because  I was a very big Drake fan for a very long time and I
'm
still maybe at the rap
level right now maybe even twenty
one Savage because I think twenty one
Savage is still the only
real rapper rapper from America who
doesn't sing now but  really
just does straight street rap
and is super successful with it
without having to make such blatant
compromises because he's
now neither able to say I'll
tell you now how it's going and
we have to get better, he'll
stop  just ignorant street rap and
is super successful with it but
otherwise I would probably also
say Drake or Travis Scott, of course that's
a bit of a
typical answer.
So if you were to
ask a business guy, I would
prefer the same thing to Beyoncé  or
or even
explodes then of course it's
probably completely somehow
with a huge waterfall of coal
but I think again on
the USA topic there are also a
lot of different things going on
so it's very often that the rappers
are only here with the engine  In the studio,
the one who records them and they
just send beats.
I know it could be that I've changed a bit,
but I think in
everyday life here, a Travis Scott
doesn't go into the studio with producers, he
just lets himself be chicken and be
Engineers play it in front of and behind it,
so this typical way
we do it, we go to the artists'
session and maybe
build the beat on the spot somehow
together with the artist and there's
not really anything like that, I think so  I just have to
differentiate a bit
between
beatmaker and then maybe
executive producer because if you
look at someone like I say
dr dre
or Rick Ruben or maybe
Mike Dean or something like that, they're just like
that or perhaps Timberland too
Although Timberland already
builds a lot of the beats themselves, they
somehow always have
teams of producers around them and do
more of the guiding vision work
on the whole brand, and that's just
in the
classic sense  and Dave says now
only a beatmaker simply
sends beats and then they record on the beat
then maybe the
beat is taken for the album but where
everything comes together and the
producer really puts the vision on the album
it's really
more like that  Executive producer and in
Germany the boundaries are disappearing
a lot, so with us it's
kind of like that we
're a mixture of
actually more of an executive
producer because we
like to take entire albums into our hands, I'll say
and also this
delivery process and relatively good
management and also the dialogue between the
artist and us but it's
still so
no idea
per artist and it's different what they
bring in themselves, so someone
like Raff or something like that is also
somehow on his own  In a way, it's also
an execute producer, that's
just how the boundaries become
much more blurred and yes, that's why I don't
think you can really compare the German and
American ways of working,
strangely enough, you can actually say something like that
for brands or something like that  That's you
talking to some companies and
having some special advertising jingles or something like that, he's not
interested in it at all, yes, that's how it works. Personally, I ca
n't imagine
working for pitches like that, so it's
just not my thing, so that's where
you really are  Service provider, in
my opinion, that no
longer has as much to do with creative work as it does with creative work. Yes,
I think we're
a bit too far for that too. Artists, so
maybe I mean never say never,
no, so if adidas comes around the corner
and says  Baumann Beat for our
new spot and do as you want and you
build a beat and
somehow get what I know 50 100000 for it, of course
you take that with you, yes, but it's just
you have to
see it that way in a figurative sense if you do it here if you now  You
go into the studio and you make a
really good song and you
somehow make a hit with the artist then
he generates similar money on the
various income streams
in the long term but you
still somehow have a little bit of this
I don't want to say ego  Kick but
so the sporting challenge for
yourself to say,
can I do something again that
is somehow successful or do
I hit the nerve of the times, do I have a good
feeling, am I developing further, what is
the next thing? Maybe that's
the claim in some way  to say what is
the scene doing right now and I
might also go away from exactly what the
scene is doing and do something completely
different and be successful with it or something like that
expectation for German music that is
coming right
now is definitely
very
techno  -house direction is somehow coming,
but I think it's getting
harder and harder to say that there's no longer
this one new thing and
everyone's doing it now, like it was somehow
five years ago, then
Bone's camera suddenly was every
second one  Song still Trapp so
now I have the feeling you
can be successful with any kind of musician
with anyone from Hip hope that they
are now in the future somehow
could be the next person
so they
definitely bring factors with me where I say
them  It's just super interesting because the
way she uses her voice
is just not a way of
singing that everyone can easily replicate.
The sound is
relatively tempo-wise and
I would say as suitable for a party as
well as suitable for Tik Tok  You've also
seen that there's a radio somewhere that's suitable for radio without gas,
that there are
a lot of interfaces that work somehow well, and
it somehow works live,
so I think you always just have to
ask yourself the general question when
you make or produce music, so where
should it be?  actually taking place now
because that's just a bit so
clear, so if I now make really
chilled out instrumental Café del Mar
music that can only be played in a stand-up café,
then maybe it can
be successful in that niche but
not on a broad and domestic level  For example,
I already think there are
enough interesting aspects with you and
different enough.
I also imagine that I'm making
a conscious decision with you
Yes, now look, not everyone can see you
now, so there will probably be a lot of
requests from people who would like to
do something with you, but you have to
choose that shares or think about
which ones my
time would be spent on in the case that you are not quite so
calculated  So I say it's
the first impression, it's just
always yes, I like the music, then
I can imagine that something cool
will come out of it, so we've already
gone into the studio with artists who basically
no one knows yet, you're now active
people
we want  I'd like to or there's
now so much demand for you
that you just
have to choose who can work with you, which is
really hard to say somehow, so there
are requests that come through
management, there are requests that just
come through Instagram or something like that
the people who are already on their
radar anyway but it's also sometimes like that
Diana way round that you somehow see
and say I think that's cool now and
you write to them or you just get to
know someone through a
contact and say hey that's it
I also go to my studio, I heard your song
and people run into each other in
our studio. I mean, if we now have
a huge study in Berlin
with a total of seven rooms where
our producers also work,
we are exactly on the border with
Charlottenburg
So it's not that far
away from the train station, so it
makes sense that when
people come from out of town, they do
n't have any further to go and so exactly and then
the scene ends up
not being as big as you think
Not in Berlin,
you're actually halfway there,
unless someone really wants to
be on your own, you'll
actually run into each other somewhere at some point,
and that's
usually the case, but social media
isn't playing so hard now  I
noticed that I have a bit of a
presence, but it seems really good to
me.
The difference is just a
little bit. I always see that as what
we can score points for,
I think, is to
really give it more in the studio and
to be reliable producers
Brainpower can also somehow be
channeled into making so much music
and it will
somehow be possible to do it so well and reliably,
so
it's not even as extreme as it was
a few years ago because
we both have children and  So
you kind of try
to get a little bit of time at home, of course, um,
but so
alternate that's exactly what it's like, so it's
just so that you're there, okay, this
and the session now with Bauens and
Dave is working very well with us, okay,
he's going  in technical matters with raff I
work very well with raffe I go there and
then you update and say to yourself, hey, can you
answer it again or whatever
comes in? You also work a lot on your cell phone. It also means
that you say okay, mix comes in  I
listen to it over my airports then
I listen to it again in the studio reference or something like that, that
's just how it is, you
're always a
little bit into it with half your head, but once you've
finished things you can
be away because of that  Others are also there
and then have your back
when you're away, so now
of course, as I said, it depends on what you do with
the work, so we're already in the studio,
I'll say five days a
week. The minimum
always depends on how many hours
What there is to do, like a profession,
you still have to work things out,
yes, the problem is that we have met there
too.
I don't want to say that I tried to
take more time for it, but the thing is,
when you start, it's just
too much  Planning everything then collides
quite badly with
the creative process because you never
know how long it will take until you
get to the result or when you have to go
back to it and have to make corrections
and when you realize that it's so
messy with each other  collides that it
then also affects the quality of the
music and simply the stress.
I notice that I'm just stressed
because I have to be creative, different
social media, hello people, by the way, that
's that, thank God, too, so
she's a little bit  I'd say the
advantage we have is that
we're producers, we're a little more
in the background, we make the music
as best we can, we loop everything because
I like to make the comparison like
when he builds a really good car,
everything fits  Every mother is tightened
there, ideally it is not
left to chance and then we give you this
good product and now you make it
fly
as an artist and then
it always depends on how well
the artist markets himself and
of course  We are also involved in
this in terms of our assessment or if we
now make producer albums ourselves then
we are even more
involved and try
to make calculated moves in a way
that we say how do we get
the song presented in a cool way now, i.e.
if we  For example, a single with
Hood black from Ludwigshafen was released
a month or so ago and then
we were in Ludwigshafen to
shoot the content for it and and and then
for our project where we were also involved,
you do that sometimes but
it's just that now  not the one if it's
not for your own album,
it's not the primary priority now,
the content is also a cost
benefit question, so exactly
who benefits from it now, what
will it be like if more people
listen to the song now if we're somehow on tiktok
without a challenge  So one way
or the other, the new one is
great, but the problem is I would
almost say again
now if everyone starts talking about it
I would almost try
to go the other way again, so of course there are
already a lot of artists who are now amazing
in the shortest possible time  For a while, we've been popping on Tiktok and
so on, we've grown up with it
and built a career out of it
and I do
n't want to rule out the possibility that it still does
n't work at all, so
generating creations like that and and and is
a great, great tool  in order to generate reach,
but I can also
imagine that, conversely,
when the mainstream jumps into it again, there will be
another phenomenon that
someone will come across, especially those that I
think you can already tell that
somehow  It's a bit over-the-top,
it's also annoying in the sense that a
lot of artists also somehow
think about it in a fashion. Hey, we need
another tiktok moment in the song and
then by that you mean
listening to music that you say hey we need
tiktok  For me, the moment is no
longer the real thing and it usually does
n't work when it's
full and the interesting thing is,
I actually always think that's the case with
the artists who have come to
stay, so now let's take
someone like that  Rinn
Bones and Raff
or now, for example, I would
say someone like Chiago or Domiziano
or something like that or Apache, exactly a
good example, they always
came into the scene through phenomena that did
n't exist before, i.e. me  I think, for
example, rin or UFO came into their fashion so strongly that they were invited into
it, so
they opened up their own fashion world
with
designer brands that then
built a scene around it, and all the kids
wanted to wear these brands too
and that's how they grew up, then
RAF and Bones were the first
gangsters to have done it and
both had crocodiles and
ravens and their animals and they were
superheroes anyway with these 187 movements and
Eurodance included, that was
again I think  what
this whole Berlin Atze Techno
gigi D'Agostino
trend is really about,
but that's also what he makes
these funny comparisons, a
bit funny
and I think what it's really all about
in essence
isn't actually that  which
medium the artist now uses, but rather
that the artist builds a cosmos around himself
that somehow creates
such an incentive and such a
tangibility for people that they say it
's now a product. I really want to work on that for
a few years
I really want
to find something beyond that, and then and
then you start
to dig into the world as a fan and so on, and
I think that's just how we as
producers have
a bit of our job to create
this cosmos  just to understand and to
tease out in the best possible way what
cool thing could you
do with it to somehow take it to the next
level or something like that and
what role does the
new company that was built for you now play, so
pay together with Raf Camora
and with Ronny Bolt, he is,
so to speak, his long-time manager
and partner and generally a hip
hop industry legend who has been around
for decades, I think, and knows
what the feeling was behind running the publishing house
in the long term or if you
sell it, it's cool or at some point
to sell them right then or what is that
you think so
we don't really have a concrete plan yet,
but first of all it's really
about collecting works together
and also really
finding producers who
can help you because we have them
Also, now there isn't quite as
much time as we
had four years ago, that you just somehow
have people who can work with or for you,
it's stupid, they
'd rather work with you like that, but of course that's
also somehow
generated by assels that you might have
can sell at some point or, to put it stupidly,
can be passive income at some point. I mean, the thing is,
you always have to see it a little bit like that.
Music is always created through
synergies anyway, you know, you actually
always have an artist who
crosses paths with you  others and
this creates a new,
beautiful flower that looks different again
and I think now if you bring in a lot of
new producers who are disciples, they will
bring in new influences that will intersect with
what we do or maybe a completely
different perspective  also have to
produce or you can
also bring something to them and you know, for example,
say hey, I see you're
currently working on an album here, um, try
to go a little bit in this and that direction in a more calculated way so that
on the one hand we're a little bit now  He also
works as a mentor for the new
producers and is
a bit of an executive
advisor to the helpers and on the other hand they are
simply a new resource for us where we
can say hey look, we are now looking
for the next Bones  Album send the sound
every few melodies we'll
involve you in the works because we
're more in a publishing house, let's
see if we can do something together
that's as cool as possible
and we've also noticed extremely
well and Ronny has it  Of course we
also noticed that because we
grew up in a RAV studio, so to speak, as
producers and of course that
happened because we did
n't have to rent a course and we
just always had a space where we
could be creative and of course we now want
it somewhere  Sounds
a bit romantic now, but what
we ourselves experienced as very positive
as idiots in the music industry and
give it back to the producers.
Look,
you have talent, we see that we
celebrate you too, and we
just want you to be without
that  Now you have this financial barrier, you
can also just get into sessions quickly, you can work quickly,
you can generate works with artists
without you saying, I
first have to buy a 15,000 euro speaker, I
first need a dry room to
record and Mike for 8000 € or what
I know  That's also added to it,
so it's a bit like that. I would
just say at the end of the day it's a
win-win situation because,
of course, as you said, we're generating it now in
our publishing house, but the way we are, I
think I almost would
One of the only publishers in
Germany claim that they
offer their producers such a blatant all-round package to work with,
that they simply
have a studio with a free head that is cleaned where
everything is there, so that's just it, um with
us it was different  So we
sold beats online and bought the
first computers and now
people can go in with their laptops and join in. There
's
a lot to do at concerts or festivals
if the opportunity arises
if somehow Raff and
are on tour with us or contra  Then
we kind of try
to always be there at two stops, but
I haven't been to a concert privately for a long time to be
honest, so it's definitely
become less because I think
it's a bit like that
too  I have to
say that somehow it stopped for me
because there were
no concerts for a long time and then they
started again but when we get
there it's somehow not so bad anymore
and probably also because of this because of
this role as a father because with us
The children are also relatively young, so
now you might
sometimes decide
to say hey, I'm
just chilling in a private setting this evening. I do
n't want to get involved in any meetings that
have anything to do with music
Lying on the couch,
playing a little Playsi and somehow just
doing sports or something like that, so yes,
the problem is, there are
so many other
obligations attached to being a teacher,
but that would have been cool for you, it would have been
cool in a way, yes, you have to
say it, but I think  Well, I
think that's a bit of a point
about this concert live and so
on, I don't even want to say it
's no longer interesting for
you at all, that was also
the respect for music and so
generally I think it's all that  It's
still really amazing what new artists are
putting on live and and and
I'm really interested in it too,
I just think you just have to
somehow keep the inner balance
between music and
being a father  family
man, maybe listen to your
own body, hey, what do
I actually need right now?
Maybe I just want to go to a spa
or something so that you do
n't get too lost in the scene
because, let me say, our industry is so
busy  There's also a lot to do with that, so if
you want, you can
go to three events every week,
drink for free everywhere, haven't you seen that, you
're invited everywhere, then there,
no, somehow, so there it is, I
think we're already there, maybe
a little bit  after exception and
maybe the car comes through this
small town life or in
general so familial, both of us are very
honored people but
somehow that was never
our priority to get lost in it
so now Udo Lindenberg can build it anyway
run over several
decades 40 50 years so it's still
possible I think so I think
someone like Apache or contra K or
Raff or something like that I or with us
I think these are people who could
theoretically still be making music in 20 years
and people would
still be interested in that,
or yes, but I'll put it this way, if
you look at someone
now, they've already
changed a little visually, even
recently, so you can already tell that it's
all a little bit
Compared to maybe
eight and nine years ago, I'm more grown up now, visually and more
serious and also a lot more business man and stuff
like that than before. I think you
can never apply that across the board to
people anyway. I think that has a lot
more to do with it  to
age with dignity, so when I
look at someone like Snoop Dog, he
no longer stands
on the corner with a bell and raps about how he
was shot yesterday, but
he still does a part here and there
on some PopColabo and
is perceived as the legend
that he is and I think if you
somehow manage to take these steps,
that's already something we're already
doing, so we're
trying to just do sessions ourselves
This mentor
position and also seeing people, he
's
still super relevant, super present, so to speak,
and doesn't do that much,
actually
released six years ago or something
in Paris with I don't know,
and rap there as if it
were all there  celebrate that and
just 50 or
two decades so they
manage to get this career so
I think it's possible so
I think it's just
a matter of taste again that you
kind of develop the right feeling
for what it's like now  also
appropriate at the moment,
what's cool right now but also I'm
still young enough to take part in it,
of course no, a sido like that, he
's made the jump and he's done it quite well for me too, some
kind of gangster rap
now I'd rather say adult
pop rap and  somehow also a television
personality and there's
nothing wrong with that at all, so I
actually think so, yes, Sido is
actually a
prime example of such a perfect
German rapper's career
in 20 years, yes, I think so, if
he's up for it,
but I think if he wants to  Well, he
's definitely intelligent enough and I
think he has a good enough feel
for it and also a team behind him who
can assess it and tell him,
hey, that makes sense and that
he can't do it, I think so, I
think someone  The raft will also be able to
do it well because he probably also
worked as a producer today.
I can also imagine a lot about him, for example,
that he will then
go a little more in the background. He also does a lot of
management and works with Ronny
Also RBK and somewhere like that,
people are
always active in their field and I
think that's just the way it is
now, even if you
go back to someone like Bones or something like that, so Bones
is now someone who has
always had a good feeling for it  had
what it's kind of cool to do that right now
and what's completely inappropriate to
somehow come up with it now that
people won't celebrate and yes once we
have this test then there's
actually not much in the way because you
can really that's the bad thing
The music industry is just super
unforgivable, especially if you
're a big artist. I think
one mistake is enough and you're no
longer cool like that, and so as a producer it
might be different because we
can throw a lot of songs into the race,
if any  If it doesn't work,
the artist with his face is
more liable for it than we are, but as an
artist, I think it's
quite a challenge to stick with it,
but there are definitely people who
can
still do it now, so I'm keeping my
fingers crossed  It's definitely
going on with you now and it's kind of a
shame for the next generation. You don't get anywhere
in the business world other than as a sports teacher or business world,
but you're
probably no longer necessary and
it's probably
enough anyway, so I had that some
time ago  The ELVIA somehow knows
the numbers, the podcast, so listen to the mistakes, you're
more interested, you should
if you do, so if you don't
make any huge mistakes then well, it should be
enough, actually
buy a catalog, yes, so it could
probably just be, I
think it'll take a while  a few
years until they really
become aware of it, okay, so whoever
heard such people exactly
not after they somehow ask for
the spelling, I don't know the
spelling, buys the rights from you,
then in case of doubt they also have the
rights to these
songs that we just talked about  In
any case, capital bra in the end you have to
ask questions, do the investors believe
that there are still 20 years
to deliver returns on these songs or dead can they
more so I think
with our
publishing catalog you can very firmly
assume that there are things there  are
still relevant in a few decades,
but I think it
's still a
bit of a time for us -
we're still so caught up in
being an actor in the whole thing -
that we're not that
crazy about the move yet  Think about it, so
10%
would really be
any anecdotes that weren't asked
or that employees didn't particularly
tell any music business. Yes,
I always find it difficult to reveal something like that, hopefully I'd be
happy to
tell it privately, but
I think that we experienced it in the
studio and so on, that's not something for this
podcast
In the sense, thank you very much
for coming, yes and good
luck, I'm excited to see where the
crates will somehow appear again soon or be
behind it, thank you very much for
allowing us to be here,
thank you very much, all clear, ciao ciao